ίναι σίγουρα τω το ίχ ίδη επισημάδι υπάρχουν βεβαίως υπάρχουν μπορεί ναδημειουργήσουμε και καινούρι εργοστάσια
στην κύπρο φυσικά όπως θα γνωρίζεται έχουμε και εργοστάσει χτός κύπρου έχουμε στην ολλανδία και
κυρίως τον βιεδνά όπου τώα έχουμε τέσσερα εργοστασία ο λόγος ήταν αφενώσομε για να μπορούμε
να προμηθέύουμε πιο ευκολα τις αγορές τις απο ανατολήσει οποι συνετεράστιε όπως γνωρίζεται αλλά τα
αυτό χρονα για να μπορούμε να παράγουμε και φι ταυτυνά προϊόντα ορισμένα προϊόντα τα οποία
είναι πολύ φτηνά στη ευρώπι στην περιοχή μας δεν μπορούν να παραχθούν με τα έξο
τα κυπριακά φεύγεσα λίγο τοποστένα πάμε στοχστ να σας ρωτήσε λίγο οι προπτικές οι ευκαιρίες
γύρω από την οικονομία αλλά και πως μπορεί να επηρεαστον οικονομίες γενικά από την εκλόγητουν
των άθρω είναι μια πολύ δύσκολιερωτήσει αλλά θα προσπαθήσουν να την απαντήσω καταπρώτο πρέπει να
ω ότι οι κπριακή οικονομία στα χέρια του φίλου μακή κιρανού παειπολύ καλά και απλειξη
αυτού είναι ότιχτές η προκτές οιμούτις μας έχουν ανεβάσει αρκετά σκαλι είναι αυτό ενοι πολύ
σκουεο πράγμα και ερπίζω να συνεχήσει οι ευρώπι έχει δυσκολίες και ιδικά